du gehst rein du spielst du gewinnst du
sofort wieder her und du trägst
sämtliche projektoren und vergiss nicht
in dieser körper kaputt geht kann ich
nicht reparieren dass alle tollste an
dem film für mich ist das was total
viele leute auf den ersten blick
abschreckt sowie leute sagen herr
gerettet gut und schön aber bitte nicht
so laut und zwar ist die tatsache dass
die hauptdarstellerinnen rosanna per
motion capture digitalisiert wurde also
ihr kopf gesicht und sie also sozusagen
nicht selbst spielt das ist in einer
zeit in der immer mehr so authentizität
aberglaube so echtheits quatsch so
wackelkamera verbirgt wahrheit im kino
stattfindet mal wieder eine erinnerung
daran was kunst eigentlich soll kunst
soll nämlich nicht nur von stoffen
handeln sondern sich auch irgendetwas
ausdenken ästhetischer art
das heißt zu sagen oh da geht es um die
armen menschen und um die versöhnung und
das gesellschaftliche problem und
deswegen geben wir den mit vier oscars
bis versinkt geht mir auf die seele
während hier diese großen augen dafür
sorgen dass man eben nicht denkt wenn
man diese person auf der straße trifft
diese schauspielerin
ach das ist jedoch die drücke ich jetzt
und machens elfi sondern der unterschied
zwischen das ist künstlich das ist
erfunden das ist science fiction dass es
spekulationen das ist ein interessantes
ding und den wirklichen alltag ist
markiert dazu kommt aber noch dass sie
die person ist die meiner meinung nach
an die circus vom thron gestoßen hat er
bis jetzt der beste motion capture
schauspieler war denn der hat im planet
der affen caesar gespielt und der hat im
herr der ringe den gollum gespielt es
ist wahnsinnig schwer so die
verschiedenen artikulationen von
gefühlen zu transportieren wenn sich
eine dumme maschine erst mal nach heft
das heißt das ist praktisch wie wenn du
einen shakespeare monolog mit
verkehrszeichen kommunizieren muss
und es darf nicht verloren gehen und die
frau macht das auf eine art dass ich
gedacht habe das ist sie und das als
jemand der mit ziemlichen erwartungen
daran gegangen ist weil als ich noch
klein und jung und noch bei 1 druckbare
war als heute fand ich den manga schon
wahnsinnig gut und das heißt der film
konnte eigentlich nur schiefgehen für
mich ist das aber nicht
von hier gibt es wegen überhöhten
überfällt hier habe ich früher gelebt
und genau hier wirst du sterben
das ist die verfilmung eines manga das
heißt eines japanischen comics von
jukebox hero und der war deswegen so gut
und ist es immer noch weil das auf dem
cyberpunk genre beruht das ist eine
unterabteilung der science fiction wo
versucht wird mit dem ganzen quatsch der
uns belästigt wie
informationstechnologie neue
kommunikationsmittel und so weiter
irgendwas ästhetisches zu machen im
westen war das hauptsächlich literatur
und ein bisschen matrix filme aber in
japan haben sie daraus einen
fantastischen visuellen stil gemacht mit
ganz vielen animes also
zeichentrickfilmen und mangas also
comics und anita ist eine der besten und
der film ist dafür dass es west nasen
wie wir sind mit irgendwie komischen
gedanken so ziemlich das beste was auf
dieser ebene des dialogs zwischen west
und ost ist jetzt passiert ist
battle angel ist kein film über die
wahre geschichte von 500 jahren wie
christoph waltz auf dem schrottplatz den
kopf einem mädchen findet dazu im körper
baut und dann in riesige schwierigkeiten
gerät die story ist dass der ziehvater
also der typ der den kopf und körper
gibt und sagt das ist jetzt mein kind
davon ausgeht dass es sein job ist ein
vater in dem sinne zu sein ich beschützt
die ich geb dir die regeln und all das
was ihm nicht so ganz klar ist dass sie
das vielleicht gar nicht will
das heißt wir haben es mit einer
emanzipationsgeschichte zu tun aber halt
bei 300 stundenkilometern also nicht mit
einer situations geschichte wie am
frühstückstisch umlagert sondern es geht
richtig viel scheiß zu bruch dabei nicht
es ist doch völlig egal was du warst
jetzt ist es nicht mehr
ich bin eine kriegerin oder und du weißt
es für die totalen kritischsten und
leute die so wie wir immer wissen wollen
welcher teil von welcher quelle wird wie
wenn man das nach diesen bänden macht
die bei carlsen erschienen sind von dem
original manga dann würde ich sagen sie
haben den zweiten teil und teile vom
dritten teil in die mitte vom ersten
teil eingekeilt weil das ende des films
ist ja das haben sich getraut
oh gott was hollywood macht sowas ja
manchmal auch toll aber es sind
sozusagen die ersten drei bände in
groben seht so wie sich sterne
das ist ein film von robert rodriguez
der so bisschen durch seine berg
gefeiert was mich angeht also manche
sachen bin ich irgendwie andere sachen
mariachi super planetary super sin city
oh mein gott bitte nie wieder so ein
film
und es ist aber auch ein film von james
cameron produziert hatten der dafür
berühmt ist dass er tolle frauenfiguren
hat also mit den aliens und linda
hamilton in terminator sarah connor und
eben diesen blech otto die chronischen
also diesen termin
das heißt roboter und tolle frauen und
diesmal ist ein roboter eine tolle frau
und es ist schon sehr starken james
cameron film von robert rodriguez in dem
sinne früher war das irgendwie auch
relativ klar in hollywood dass es pro
user filme gibt und regisseurs filme das
heißt die bunten horrorfilme von newton
zum beispiel der war einfach produzent
und selbst jacques tourneur hat dann
gesagt dann mache ich einen guten film
selbst robert zemeckis hat steven
spielberg filme gemacht das ist nicht
ehrenrührig in irgendeiner form die
müssen alle zusammenarbeiten und
entweder rodriguez hat total erraten was
cameron will oder cameron hat sich
zurückgehalten jedenfalls ist es der
film von james cameron der mich am
meisten interessiert und begeistert hat
seit terminator 2
denn dazwischen hat er so zeug gemacht
wo man sich fragt warum muss das science
fiction sein weil wenn ich der mit dem
wolf tanzt noch mal machen mit
langgezogenen schlümpfen dass amazon was
soll das ich verstehe es nicht ja und
bei diesem ding hier war ich so happy
wie nicht mehr seit my little pony so
traurig wie nicht mehr seit er dort von
corinna und so melancholisch wie nicht
mehr seit melancholia fand die frau in
meiner erinnerung
99 was du gesehen hast war ein
aufblitzen seines früheren lebens mit
der zeit hast du dich erinnern
ich glaube zwei gruppen von leuten
sollten besonders dringend da rein leute
die von nichts eine ahnung haben 15 sind
und kinofilme am liebsten im handy
gucken weil die man sich wundern was man
außerhalb des handys so alles sehen kann
bis einem die ohren abfallen die pippi
langstrumpf und dann leute die gerne
wahnsinnig viel zeug noch wissen wollen
über die wird 500 jahren oder wie
sieht's denn mit der frage aus ob
menschen auch in zweck kamen gegen gerät
und was wird wenn menschen immer mehr
wie geräte werden ich meine künstliches
hüftgelenk hier kontaktlinsen und so wir
sind ja alle cyborgs wer sich also über
schwierige bioethische fragen gerne
unterhält der kann das auch bleiben
lassen und sich von einem film zu diesen
themen einfach mal an prüfen lassen
offene total netter